so if we now step into returning to our
friend sam harris and step into this
weird place of science and you talked
about this where the the kind of the
current assumption of science is
it's a materialistic one
uh so for me obviously ai person
this whole mind thing is fascinating
like what the heck is going on up there
uh so how do you explain consciousness
how do you explain free will do you
think first of all do you think we have
a free will and if so what is it
this is where
we had the debate um earlier that i
mentioned with hitchens where i think
actually neither he nor the moderator
understood what i was saying which is
i'm sure my inability to express it but
he was very focused and delivered on
on the humor yes and the wit yes but
what i was trying to say is
if we're entirely biological creatures
if we didn't choose our genetics and we
didn't choose our environment
then there is no space for free choice i
don't understand where it comes in and i
kept asking them that question but
didn't get an answer because i don't
think there is an answer i think
if you're a thorough going materialist
free will is impossible there could be
randomness but randomness is not free
will it's randomness
i think you need a spiritual
um non-material belief in order to get
free will
and that's why i believe in free will
yeah you were talking about sort of yeah
and actually the moderator totally
missed your point about the glass of
water and basically how what was the
difference so do you free will
because you could also if it fits into
the materialistic picture it could be
just a convenient useful quirk you would
understand this better than i i don't
understand how it could be
a convenient quirk materialistically i
don't understand how to explain it well
no there's you know if you study
perception there's all these kinds of
illusions right we
are
our mind plays tricks on us yes
to make our life easier more efficient
and survive better and all those kinds
of things and so free the the feeling
like we have a choice oh that could be
an illusion yeah i understand right but
but actual free choice free will i don't
see where you get it if you're a
materialist i think you have to have
a spiritual component by the way this i
think this is also i think sam would
agree with this
um i think he wrote about not having not
having free will yeah
and i think if you don't have a god and
you don't have uh a soul
that free will is a logical
impossibility
for sam which is fascinating it's not
just that free will is an illusion but
uh
the illusion of free will is an illusion
meaning there's not we don't even
experience anything like it there's no
illusion we're like
it's not even on us to be talking about
it we're just we are like the
the the the current in the river or
something that you were comparing it to
the glass we are just like that glass
right so i don't know what we're going
on about with this whole free will thing
uh i mean
to use the free world fund the i that
the young person is born with is that
somehow fundamental to
religion i think it's fundamental to
judaism i i think that the i the idea is
that
you are the custodian of your soul
and even though i grant that there's a
certain over
um emphasis
in modern society on the individuality
of the soul
that is we are more interconnected
than i think
who we are
we believe
um
still
yeah the i the idea that every human
being is an image of god that i mean
that the human being in the torah is is
created singly and again do i really
believe there was an adam and an eve and
a garden of eden no not literally
but i think that it's it expresses a
deep truth about human life
you